I'm here with Kathleen Mullaney,
who's the Vice President
of Careers here at Udacity.
Kathleen, thank you so
much for talking to us today.
>> Thank you, David.
>> So I want to talk to Kathleen
about issues of gender in educational
technology.
So the first thing I'd ask is, there
is a trend in educational technology,
that because the technology
industry is so dominated by men,
the things we create in Ed Tech,
are often very oriented towards men.
So what can we do to kind of try and
break that cycle?
>> When I first started at Udacity back
when we were creating the first courses,
we realized that this was actually
going to become quite prevalent.
The first courses we
launched were CS 101,
which is into to computer
programming in Python.
The focus was how to
build a search engine.
And the second course was an A.I. course
focused on how to program a robotic car.
And those seem pretty agnostic.
Now a car and
a search engine are not gender based.
But, there is a tendency to view
those actually as more male oriented.
Like cars in general
are more focused on men.
And we realize that, actually just
choosing topics for the courses and
the examples that we use in courses
could have a great effect on whether or
not men or women would be attracted
to take the course to begin with.
It's like one of the things that
we really focused on was trying,
after we saw those first courses and
thought about how we want to market
future courses, we actually took
a more broadened perspective.
And we tried to actually make things
as agnostic as we possibly could, and
had much more attention to it.
So the first thing that I always tell
people is that you didn't need to be
aware of the stereotypes that exist for
everybody.
Including I have many stereotypes
of men and women myself,
even though I am very well
educated on this topic.
And so keeping those in mind, and
keeping them at your forefront when
you're designing any kind of
materials it is crucially important,
making sure that you're not playing
into any standard gender archetypes.
So another example from
the History of Udacity is
that we produce this course
on Tales from the Genome.
So it was about genetics.
And we had a male and
a female instructor, and
the male was the expert, and
the female was the novice.
And they played this really
nice dynamic on film,
where the novice would
ask the expert questions.
There were times,
though, in the filming,
that we realized that we were
essentially portraying the female
as this dumb person who didn't
know the answers to things.
When really, she's very intelligent and
has her own background.
She's just not a geneticist.
And that was what we were
trying to portray there.
We didn't want to say that one
person is smarter than the other,
but this person just doesn't
have this expertise.
And it was something that we
didn't actually realize until
pretty far into filming the course.
And we went through and
actually looked through every video and
actually said, do we feel that this is
portraying women in a negative light?
Or playing into these easy
archetypes that, films so
often use, a woman in distress.
She needs help.
She needs to be saved by this
knight in shining armor.
And we ended up cutting a lot
of content and changing it,
because we realized we just don't want
to be portraying women in that light.
Another example just to, again, to give
you an idea of how much this is very
prevalent and how much we don't even
realize it, is that there's a video in
one of our job rescript courses that had
a complaint from a student that said why
are you playing into these gender roles?
Haven't you heard of stereotype threat?
If you haven't heard
of stereotype threat,
that's where basically
reinforcing a stereotype
in the context where a stereotype
is typically threatened.
I guess that's the name, is more likely
to cause those issues than not, so, for
example, women are told by society that
they're not as good at math as men are.
And if you ask the woman to state her
gender before she takes a math test,
she will do worse on that math test.
And so, that's what stereotype is,
as an example.
And what we realized is that,
we were naming variables
in this JavaScript course.
Completely what we thought was benign.
But somebody saw that, you know,
we named one of the variables gal.
The variable it was supposed to be
a hero so it was definitely portraying
women in a positive light, but
pointing out that there are women
in a situation where they may already
feel that they're not confident.
May actually cause people to
think of their abilities as less,
which I don't necessarily agree in this
scenario but just to point out the of
the issues that may come up and how
much you do need to be aware of them.
So I would say like the basic thing that
you can do is to educate yourself on
on the dynamics that
we know exist today.
So talking about stereotypes and
bias in particular.
And not only with gender, though I don't
if we're talking about diversity at
large, but
as with any underrepresented group.
In computer science or
in technology in general.
>> Yeah.
Do you know, and
I assume your familiar with imposter
syndrome in this context as well, can
you comment on that in the same kind of-
>> Yeah,
it's very similar to stereotyping.
They go hand in hand oftentimes.
So imposter syndrome is that,
and I feel this all the time.
I'm a high-level executive at this
company, and I still feel this.
>> I have a PhD, and
I feel the exact same way.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH] It's like oh I don't
have the answer to this yeah.
It's basically you feel that
you don't have the expertise
that you need to fulfill a position or
fulfill a job.
And this is actually one of
the things that I mentor girls,
especially the girls who code groups
that nobody knows what they're doing.
Nobody, I mean it.
Like I don't know any one person who
actually knows what they're doing all
the time.
And it's fun to actually at least be
in the start of environment because
we try to raise that fact as
much as we possibly really can.
I don't know if Sebastian liked
to mention his failure award.
So if you try to break the company,
and we've succeeded at various points.
>> [LAUGH] Yes we have.
>> He rewards you with a bottle of wine,
a nice bottle of wine.
And the whole point here is that
it's said to highlight this fact,
I think at least,
to counter this imposter syndrome,
that you're acting out of fear because
you think that you can't do something.
Because you're not smart enough or
you don't have the right experience or
the number of years of experience or
the specific background.
A number of people at Udacity
work in computer science.
They don't have computer
science degrees.
A number of our students in particular
do not have computer science degrees but
are looking to get into
the technical field.
One of the most frequent questions
I receive is really focusing on
how can I get a job here when
they say a CS degree is required.
I have to counsel people on they say
this but that's really just this
shortcut that people use to say
people just want a certain level of
understanding of these topics or
a certain level of work experience.
And time after time I talk to employers
and actually tried to assist this out.
And they say, no,
we don't actually want assist really,
we just really want to know
like do you know this stuff.
And so that's what we focus on
Udacity its like know the stuff, and
do it in a way that is more flexible and
it meet your needs rather than having to
go back and
get a second degree often times.
>> Yeah.
>> That
was a very long answer to that question.
[LAUGH]
>> That's all right.
I ask on imposter syndrome because
we've done some interesting research on
imposter syndrome in the OMS.
And it's interesting that the research
came out that suggested that
people who experience imposter
syndrome more strongly
are less likely to take a chance on
an experimental program like this.
>> Yes, exactly.
>> Because
if it doesn't end up panning out,
it reflects poorly on me.
And I'm already an imposter,
so now people recognize that.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> And so,
I think combating that in
this program is really,
really important because it
helps increase our diversity.
Because the people who more often
experience that are the ones we
really want in this program anyway.
>> Yeah, have you talked about growth or
fixed mindsets in that context?
>> We've talked about it a little
bit in one of the other lessons
on motivation and meta cognition.
So yeah.
>> Yeah, one of
the best ways to counteract an imposter
syndrome is to have a growth mindset
intervention to highlight that, you
know making mistakes helps you learn.
It doesn't actually show
that you're stupid or
that you don't have
the ability to do something.
>> Yeah.
In fact, no one ever learns
really anything except for by failure.
>> Yeah exactly.
>> So Kathleen will agree with me that
mindset is the one book that everyone
should read I assume.
>> Yep. Yep. [LAUGH]
>> And so
we talk a lot about doing
this in Ed Tech and
how to design educational technology
initiatives that do this.
But many of our students probably
won't go into this field, but
they'll go into fields that
suffer from these same issues.
>> Yep, totally.
>> So
just when they're on
the job in the future,
what can they do to try and
improve diversity in their workplace,
without being kind of pandering, or
some of the things we more often see?
>> Sure, yeah, I guess the first
thing is that if you are not
an underrepresented group that
doesn't mean you can't participate in
trying to actually alleviate
the issues that these groups encounter.
If you are a white male, sorry Dave.
>> It's okay.
>> The things you can do are educate
yourself and help promote
these issues to other people.
I noticed actually when I first
brought up the issue of bias and
stereotype with the company here, one of
the things that came up, is you're like,
I am a white man, I feel like I can't
participate, because I'm the enemy.
No, you're not the enemy,
that's actually not what
we're trying to say here.
A stereotype is a shortcut
in your cognitive process.
It's something that you see something
over and over and over again, and
your brain just makes a shortcut.
And it helps you think about things.
It actually helps you in
your life quite a bit.
We're not saying that
all stereotypes are bad.
You just need to understand
the ones that are,
and the ones that result in
poor judgment or behavior.
And a bias also is the shortcut,
but it's also an error.
So if you talk about like in research.
A bias is actually just
an error in measurement.
And so what we want to do
is actually just again,
the awareness of these things helps
cut down the effects of them.
I don't know the exact statistic
right now, but a pretty big amount.
And so educate yourself on the issues
that face people in these groups.
So for the technology industry,
it's something about
20 to 30% female on a good day and
if that's the case,
then what are the things you can do
to actually get, to be more equal.
And actually, probably educating
yourself on why that's even important.
The point isn't just to have equality,
the point is to have
diversity of thought.
And you're not going to have diversity
of thought if everybody looks the same,
has had the same education,
comes from the same type of family and
from the same like economic background.
So businesses,
it's actually shown you know through
research again that businesses that
have diverse employees are more
successful than ones that are not.
So understanding like why
you actually want this and
the more logical reasons rather than
the emotional ones are just like I
don't want there to be inequality.
And actually try to
move the needle based
on logic rather than emotional
responses to the situation.
>> Have you read Thinking Fast and Slow?
>> Yeah it's a good book.
>> If you all haven't heard of it,
it's a great book.
I wouldn't have even
connected it to this, but
I'm glad you mentioned about shortcuts.
It talks a lot about how
stereotypes are just kind of
easy ways to think that
we fall into because
we can't think deeply about every
single thing we encounter all day long.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> But
being aware of them is really
the quickest way to know
when you're doing it badly.
>> And not feeling like
you're doing something wrong.
>> Yeah.
>> I noticed another example.
Hopefully theses are helpful for
you guys.
One of the stereotypes,
and again the biases,
that comes in to play is that women are
more often judged by their character,
so by how likable they are, and men
are more often judged by their skills.
Which is really ridiculous, especially
when it comes into interviewing.
And so
it's something that I work on very,
very much with our Udacity students
in helping them apply for jobs.
For the most part people
are not interviewing you for
how likable you are.
They're interviewing you because they
want you to perform a specific function
in a company.
And it's important for if you're
an interviewer to remember that and
also as an interviewee because you
want to make sure that you're not giving
any easy paths for an interviewer
to fall into and basically say, oh,
I'm going to choose the shortcut.
And so the things that you can actually
do are to enforce that you have
the skills for a job, in your rhetoric
in your answers to interview questions.
Highlight that you have the skills.
Don't just smile a lot and be likeable.
That's also an important trait.
I'm not saying that that's
not important at all,
but you can make it easier for
yourself and for
the people who can easily be tracked
by stereotypes to come out on top.
I know that when I was interviewing for
a candidate I was writing all of my
feedback about this interview that I had
just completed and I was saying how she
had a really sunny disposition and
I was like, what am I talking about?
That has nothing to do with this job and
for me,
once I realized that, that's when
I decided actually to start doing
these talks here at Udacity because if
I, this is one of my favorite topics.
If I'm so susceptible to this despite
the amount that I read about it,
that I do my research,
that I try to help others and
I'm still falling into these traps.
We need to make it as prevalent so
that I have support.
So I get a team of people to help
me actually do better myself.
It's kind of like if you're
trying to lose weight.
You're much more likely to
succeed if you have some social
pressure to help you
with achieving your goal.
>> Yeah absolutely.
>> So if you wife was to say,
David you're trying to lose weight, so
let's make sure we're not keeping
cookies in the house, or whatever.
You're going to have more support.
And so-
>> Yeah exactly.
Accountability.
>> Exactly.
So this accountability is important if
we're able to help each other learn
about these things and be active,
rather than passive about
the efforts to improve them.
Personally, I think that's what
would lead to more success.
>> Yeah, absolutely, I agree completely.
Do you have any last thoughts you
want to share with our students, as they
prepare to embark on their projects,
or maybe wrap up their projects?
>> Yeah, I guess one of the things that
I wish I had understood a little sooner,
was really think about,
if you're designing a course or
a product, think about your learner or
your user.
And really understand who that person
is, or who that group of people are.
And do your best to limit it,
because making a product for
everybody will never win.
And really try to reach that person.
I mean I think once we were
able to actually figure out
some of the individuals that we were
reaching with the Udacity courses.
We got a lot better about creating
content that fit their needs.
I think really just focus on your user,
and make sure that
you know who that person is, so that
you are solving a problem for them, or
you're helping them achieve whatever
goal that they're trying to achieve.
>> Make sense.
>> Yeah.
>> Well great.
Thank you so much for
talking to us today, Kathleen.
>> Thanks for having me.
Good luck with your projects.
[SOUND]
>> [LAUGH]